All right, you're done.
Let's look at the solution.
As I said in the question,
we're going to be
working inside a forecast fragment
in the updateWeather function.
First, we're going to need
to create a standard intent
for our alarm receiver.
We then add our location query
as an extra.
We then wrap that in a PendingIntent.
A pending intent is a
special kind of object
that describes an intent.
This allows other applications
to implement the feature
of the original intent that's used
to create the PendingIntent.
We're only going to use
this PendingIntent once,
so I set Flag One Shot.
Then, we get the alarm service
and set the alarm
to trigger five seconds from now.
But we still need for our alarm
to do something.
Back in the Broadcast Receiver,
we need to send
the standard intent
to start our service, and that's it.
Let's try running the app.
All right, so now we've got
the Alarm Manager
getting in the way of our service.
We hit refresh.
It'll take us about
five more seconds
before we actually see the data now.
And there we have it -
a very, very simple alarm.
Even with this updating
in the background potentially,
and using a service,
we could still be more efficient
in our use of phone resources.
Rato can tell us more about that.